hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my brand new 400 part
series on goat simulator let's go set
another code over there hi bad sorry did
I run you over there are you to my new
friend are you bab come here with me I'm
gonna take you with me we need to go on
an adventure
hello everybody I said hello everybody
did you see my new friend Bab hey don't
run away from me with my Bob go Bab Bab
you're not Bob about all this Bob I've
got stuck on the fence we okay I got Bob
by the button
come with me Bob we got places to go we
got things to do we got things to Steve
Boosh oh my god
Wow I don't think I'm supposed to go
this far
what the hell oh I found stone edge
apparently wish ow
so what did I find over here this uh C
Gua all right wait a minute can I take
one of these oh my god oh I got a stone
edge aah aah get out of my way I got
things to do I got people to see I got
so many things to go to we Jimmy have
you seen my new friend Bob my god hey
like my friend Bob you like my friend
BAM
Wow God oh oh you wanna be huh huh huh
ah jeez you're strong I find me and Bob
are gonna go somewhere else boom
I didn't hurt Chuck
I didn't mean to do that
sorry hey me my friend Bob hello you
want to be my friend oh oh oh this is
ridiculous Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam you
don't want to come up here ba bam bam
hey there yard Bob thanks for joining me
Bob
hey buddy and goodbye no pull off Bob oh
there's Bob you gotta be kidding me
oh no I've gots dark come save you Bob
see ha ha ha ma'am Bab Bab Bab curse
turn it Bob you son of a [ __ ] Bob I
can't believe you do this to me buddy
This Is It this is my mama but time to
shine
no oh hey get back up
dad oh oh we're going Oh God why don't
wants to be my best friend Bob Oh
oh he's ours on the trailer whoa Oh God
follow me you can only see me now do you
want to be my new friend Bab hey come
here I wanna be your friend whee oh wait
I wanna be my friend okay never mind
then bye what's in here huh what is this
what what is this what our picture I got
a jet pack in a power pitcher I'll just
make any damn sense
well the hell am i doing what
Oh am i welcome at your dance party I
think you'll find that I can breakdance
bro okay never mind then lady do you
want to be my friend okay never mind
sorry wait you're coming with me
Wow
oh I got a new best friend finally hi oh
nice dance you got there
hey hey hey come on now I know we
haven't been friends before but when you
wanted me in my new friend Bab we he
okay never mind then bag and Roque
Bonnie I wanna call you Bonnie
hi ow
hey cool oh hush
oh hello can i headbutt you what are you
what are this what's higher this was our
this hi lady
oh it's Bob it's Barney hey Barney hey
Bonnie I want to I want to say how do
you hang on for hours
hi I'm gonna get there eventually swirls
and hold on a second
shoosh I'm coming for ya Oh God where
are you hello
yep but oppa do oh I see over there over
there over there over there not over
here over there come on over there quick
aim fire okay all right okay almost
almost almost connect flexibility there
hi Bonnie
did you miss me baby Bonnie Manny Manny
Manny Manny Manny Fannie Fannie Fannie
Fannie Fannie okay
you okay pani yeah okay you're coming
with me no no no Bonnie I didn't mean it
knowing Bonnie I'm sorry Bonnie I'm
sorry let's go forever and ever and ever
and ever
so then we'll always be together okay I
got you
all right we're going this time push
we're getting out here I'm saving you
Bonnie we're gonna be together forever
what my lanes Lynne shut up Bonnie I
know my name is line we got a name is
line you're gonna be Bonnie from now on
push blue boxes hello boxes go Mary
boxes boxes nice to see how to me but
access Max's boxes by bus bye Oh goodbye
and away we go
into the sunset we shall dwell into the
ground first put into the sunset
later shoosh I'll save you kind of just
got a point in the right direction and
shoot chipper Jets Jimmie Johnson ow no
time to tumble in the grass we gotta go
hmm you seem to be a bit on fire Bonnie
you want to put that out for me I don't
care for smokers does anyone want to say
hi to me does anyone want to play I got
my date here I'm ready for dinner
is anyone wanna know Yes No maybe so hi
hello how you doing you good
I see you did not be working on anything
so that's okay hi how's it going
sighing anyway I apologize sincerely
okay this is lovely stuff that you have
in here interior decorating is just a
life--all Bonnie come on we're out of
here I gotta be honest Bonnie you're
being a little bit of a douche friend
you're not really interacting with me
very much I sometimes feel like I'm
carrying the whole burden of this hello
wanna be my friend Poosh Wow no you come
back here you [ __ ] oh what's your point
huh Oh Bonnie
what happened Bonnie what happened
Bonnie are you okay
Bonnie are you all right Bonnie just
talk to me Bonnie I think she's fine I
think she's good I think he's totally
fine okay okay there's my butt what's
getting out of there
what seems to be but broken so we're
down here now Bonnie did you have too
much to drink Bonnie I wonder if we put
enough baseballs down here forever okay
and we're gone by bonnie into the biz we
go goodbye world goodbye everyone
goodbye and forever this is the end for
us all so anyway that was goat simulator
utterly and completely ridiculous and
yet somehow absolutely essential to the
gaming community so if you want to see
more of this game let me know in the
comments below especially if you want me
to play with my actual best friend Bob
and also don't forget to leave a like
down below for more thanks again
everybody for watching
as always I will see